[Music]
my name is mariam my name is allah
and i am a libyan american living in
pennsylvania where do i say i'm from and
i
am a palestinian iraqi brit living in
new york but now
staying with maryam in pennsylvania and
that's my friend from new york by way of
the uk she's been spending ramadan with
my family
because she was living in new york we
just couldn't have allah spending
ramadan by herself
so she came a couple weeks before
ramadan so we could quarantine
and then has been with us ever since so
ramadan
is a holy month in islam it's a month of
fasting so muslims around the world wake
up at dawn
or before dawn and eat what's called and
then they fast
from all food and water until marib or
sunset we don't eat or drink anything
yes
not even water so had it not been for
quarantine my ramadan would definitely
look a little bit different definitely
would have been seeing a lot more
friends
having dinner with a lot of people
friends loved ones family members
i would have been completely by myself
in new york in my really tiny apartment
probably breaking my fast every day
alone and really really missing my
family i felt
very very blessed and very very lucky to
have family who's taking me in like one
of their own
getting emotional
stop it the fact that uh maryam's family
have welcomed me
with open arms encapsulates what the
spirit of ramadan is about
okay so the first thing that we're
preparing or i'm preparing today
is gd which is basically libyan
lamb jerky started the process yesterday
and basically
cut up the lamb and seasoned it and just
left it to sit overnight
and so that's what it looks like and
then now we have to put it in the
dehydrator
for like six or seven hours we've been
quite creative yeah
a lot of that is i wish you guys could
have like a slideshow of all the
different foods
we've actually made at this point
[Music]
okay so alas helping me out getting a
head start on the monkey
just slicing and dicing some onions just
adding some onions
so that we can boil the chicken so
making essentially the broth
we've all been going through very
different like variations
of ramadan i guess at different points
throughout the month indeed
is in process it smells really good
but it's interesting i feel like we all
have very different experiences on a
day-to-day basis
but we're not uncomfortable sharing them
i mean it's it's
it's been a great month it's been
memorable there's been a lot of laughs
yeah a lot of laughs a lot of lost i'm
gonna miss that kitchen
hello my name is iman i am from
minnesota but i currently live
in seoul south korea wow my ramadan has
already been so different since living
in korea for about
over five years now um but here in korea
it's i would say it's a very lonely
ramadan
in quarantine my situation is a bit
different because seoul is not
necessarily on lockdown
we are just social distancing you know
taking the necessary precautions wearing
masks wherever we go
and you know following whatever
guidelines and rules the
government puts out before there were no
regulations right
to prevent us from going to the mosque
and praying
in congregation or meeting up for iftars
and breaking our fasts
with friends or hanging out on the
weekends and then having to hurt
together
at a 24 hour restaurant and whatnot so i
feel like the fact that we have to
follow and abide
specific rules that's what's changed
feeling really restricted
i still go to work i definitely have to
wear a mask
my contact with people is very different
even my students are
all spread out within the classroom
they're not too close together i
wouldn't
break my fast again with family and
whatnot i'm usually teaching at that
time
so i do take a moment to break my fast
and then
get right back to work my situation is
very very very unique
to this whole ramadan experience than
most people but
definitely making it work and making the
best of it
hi my name is lima dashboor i'm from
jordan i'm living in amman
and ramadan this year would have been
completely different if it wasn't
for quarantine so for me ramadan has
always been the most social time of the
year
you get to catch up with all of the
family and friends that you don't
usually
have the time to see during the year and
sit together and have a great meal
usually you are invited to somebody
solid every single day unfortunately
this year has been completely different
i'm actually a fashion designer and
ramadan is usually a very busy time for
us
unfortunately this year we had no orders
for
outfits for eid or for the weddings that
usually happen after ramadan which
were all completely cancelled so this is
one of the
busiest streets in amnan for buying
shoes and dresses and then as you can
see there's not many people inside even
though
we're only two days away from uh
in jordan we were forced to be home
by 7pm where sunset is around
at 8 and you're not allowed to use your
car every single day
so it would depend on your license plate
if it's
an odd or even number so that they
didn't want too many people in the
streets
so this is rainbow street which is
usually a very busy street filled with
restaurants
it's fully closed not a lot of people
are walking here
most of the shops are closed with no
customers inside
the sirens go off at around 7pm so you
need to make sure that you're done
and you're home if it's the time that
you're allowed to drive in
it did create a special memory where i
found out that i can actually cook
great food every single day and that you
are capable of cooking nonetheless even
though
we were very lonely during this time i
think that it was the only ramadan that
wasn't so busy
and kind of focusing on yourself and and
to have a little bit more of a spiritual
ramadan
in my opinion even though it has been an
unusual ramadan but i'm very
optimistic and hopeful for uh what's
next
[Music]
abu dhabi quarantine chronicles
and ramadan vlog madan whatever you want
to call it
it's your girl henan and you guys are
going to be coming along with me
on my journey today i forgot to mention
i'm not from abu dhabi
from seattle and i got stuck here about
two months ago
came to visit and my flight was
suspended
and i've been stuck here ever since i'm
one of the lucky ones though because
abu dhabi is basically home i was born
here and it's kind of home away from
home
i'm not stuck here i'd just say it's an
extended vacation
abu dhabi is very interesting because
they've implemented a lockdown
where the residents are not able to go
out during
you know typical ramadan hours but since
the coba 19 pandemic
we are not allowed to be out after 10
p.m
since you fasten all day you want to go
out after 10 pm but
you can't because cover 19 it's locked
down they do a sanitation i'm gonna
bring you guys along with me
going to the grocery store typically i
would not leave during the day when i'm
fasting just because you know
i'd be hungry we be hungry and you don't
want to lose your energy
so you guys are going to come along with
me so in order to
be outside you are required to wear a
mask it's not optional
it's a governmental mandate like
everyone has to wear masks
stores will provide you with gloves like
they take your
fever when you're walking in so i'm
going to see if i can get this on camera
okay so my mask broke and i can't go
into the wall without a mask
but thank god he has a mess for me
replacement mask on deck
we made it in the mall we have to wear
gloves
is this required i guess in the mall
it's required
everything is shut down literally only
thing open in this
place is the grocery store down there
that's it
stickers around the mall implementing
social distancing you have to maintain a
distance
of three steps this is so crazy because
in in like the west in america and like
london and stuff
you would never see celebrate you would
never see eat sales ramadan sales like
this is so normal here so we made it
back home
and there's about how long
[Music]
40 minutes left i can't wait to eat i'm
so hungry i'll show you guys what we
were having for iftar should we lie and
say we cook the biryani
[Music]
right okay so i'm gonna show you guys
what we cooked
these are two ramadan staples dates
and retail you don't know what binto is
go out and try
it it's bangin
[Music]
[Applause]
my name is zayn i am originally lebanese
and palestinian
i was born and raised in london which is
where i am right now so i graduated from
medical school last august i don't think
a typical day
in quarantine ramadan actually exists
for me it's been a bit weird in that
sense
like some days i'm super productive like
revising my arabic notes revising my
medical notes
making loads of music and then other
days it's just literally me lazing
around the house
good morning guys so i've just woken up
so i'm just heading over to the studio
space we've built at the back of our
garden that's where i've been the most
productive
the first thing i'm going to do today is
start doing some arabic homework ever
since quarantine started i haven't been
able to do
lessons in person so i have an arabic
tutor who i meet with twice a week
virtually so i've got some homework for
tomorrow and that's what i'll probably
do for the next half an hour when the
situation started getting quite bad i
was actually in lebanon so they
literally gave us
three days to catch a flight back to our
homes otherwise we'd have been stuck
there so
i was probably being in lebanon studying
classical arabic
making loads of music relaxing chilling
out one of my friends from canada his
name is cuckoo really cool producer so
we're just gonna have a meeting and see
exactly what he needs
bro this is so good honestly okay i'm
gonna
i'm gonna spend some time recording to
it
i'll be on the way
tonight for a start we will be having
mana ish
which is kind of like a lebanese pizza i
think some of my favorite memories
from this ramadan have been the ones of
me and my dad in the kitchen
learning his recipes learning the
stories behind those recipes
are things i've never really had the
opportunity to do before
i think that's that's been my favorite
thing i think in a nutshell this ramadan
has just been
very different it has its pros and it
has its cons but
i've never really had a ramadan like
this thanks for joining
a day in my life in ramadan and
quarantine i hope it was insightful
[Music]
peace
[Music]
you